you speak as if the set of cleanup
volunteers and the set of rioters are
disjoint
how much overlap is there what does it
mean if the overlap is significant
that would be fascinating um if it was
actually the same people and i would
actually that would change
what i think is going on a lot but i see
no evidence at all that there is
any overlap in fact of the i think i
counted 11 different volunteers
that we saw today and um
one of the last two as we were walking
back to our car um was actually wearing
a black lives matter t-shirt and i
commented to you yep
i said um wow that's a level oh there's
a spider on the table crawling up here
oh my god it's probably in your shirt
now
i'm cool with this i i like spiders i
don't
it's on my sleeve though we're good
let me know if you see it again i'm the
one wearing loose pants
i'm gonna curl up my leg okay um it's a
fast moving so it came from here so
maybe it's done with me
okay there was there's someone one of
these volunteers was wearing a black
lives matter t-shirt and i said to you
that is a
a remarkable level of cognitive
dissonance
to be here cleaning up from the riots um
and then be proclaiming
um something that you really i again i
don't feel like any of the stuff that's
going on at the
at the literal rioting and looting level
in portland right now is actually black
lives matter
it's completely tightly joined and it's
confused the anarchists and the looters
and the vandals and everything have
confused people
and want that to be their branding but i
don't i don't think it mostly is but
but still you know to be like oh you
know i'm for this thing that claims to
be doing this destruction
and now i'm out here cleaning out the
destruction seems like
a level of confusion that i wouldn't
normally expect but really no one else
that i saw a was wearing any of the
branding but
also i mean these mostly were either
young like
high school and like cleanly like
cleanly quaffed and sort of almost like
properly dressed if that's even a thing
anymore like
t uh high schooler and college age kids
and then
like middle aged there were there were a
couple of middle-aged asian women
and um it just it was it's not the same
people
who are out there i mean we weren't out
there last night but we've see
we've been out there in other times and
it was totally different from the people
who were
hanging out outside their tents feeling
you know
being however they're being it's not
them either who's doing it the clean app
i don't know if they were involved in
the rioting zero reason to expect
overlap
um i do wonder given your point about
who
was doing cleanup if something has
caused those with a public service
requirement in high school or something
to end up
there were two different sets of
t-shirts that i saw on the
volunteers as if there are two different
organizations ngos
of some sort non-governmental
organizations of some sort who are
sending out people to clean up
yeah um and yeah the younger people all
i don't remember i'm gonna have the
pictures but i don't remember offhand
i think they all were wearing the one
type of shirt and then
a bunch of the other people wearing
something else so there might be yeah
i will say it might be that one of the
things i didn't i didn't capture it this
morning but
uh one of the things that disturbs me
most about the
wanton destruction is how frequently
things like trash cans
are destroyed and i think the point is
the instinct
is to turn portland into a mess
it is completely antithetical to the
impulse to clean up
after the mess right so the idea anybody
who likes portland to be a nice place
wants there to be trash cans that get
emptied
because then there isn't trash all over
the place so you know do you
want homeless people to have a better
quality of life trash cans contribute to
that yes
right so you know there's just no
argument that this is
uh complex these are people who
[Music]
just see structure as antithetical
and have set about destroying it and
those who would
set about cleaning it up whatever their
impulse it is different
yeah um
so just a few a few comments here and
uh several will riff one person says i
went down
i went downtown for the first time in
over a year and my heart broke because i
saw what they've done to my city
it's childlike misdirected anger
i saw your street photos and felt i was
watching guilty portland parents
cleaning up after their poorly raised
and riotous offspring
are they enablers uh
if a rioter breaks a window in the
forest and no one is around to fear it
are all cops still bastards that is
philosophical
portland might not have all its ducks in
a row but its cats better get in line
this is a little worrying i just want
everyone to be aware that the insanity
on the left has started screenshotting
super chats and using it as a weapon
against
the talent i don't know what the
evidence for that is but that's not good
i don't even know what that would mean
but it doesn't sound good yeah i mean i
don't i see oh i get it i see very
little in our super chats
that are bad but um please start a
movement to stop cleaning up after riot
so people deal with the consequences
uh merci love you former story time here
i'm not sure what story time is
um and then two more and then we'll talk
about
any of these we are talking about i
appreciate you're covering the riots in
downtown pdx
portland as a resident of downtown i
find that more support
as a resident of downtown i find that
most portlanders are
willfully question mark ignorant of what
is really going on in our city
yeah i think so um one more why does the
left media
and black lives matter martyr men who
have been criminally violent towards
women and then never mention the charges
and that's you know a little bit
different and so let's definitely get to
that one but
anything from all of those interesting
and uh diverse
comments about portland i mean we we
spent a lot of time talking about and i
appreciate
i always appreciate hearing from people
um who are well familiar with portland
who are here
um yeah and you know we actually like
four or five people
that recognized us when we were down
there today and that was
intriguing of course you know people who
are interested in what's happening to
portland who live here
are likely to have gone down and likely
right so you know it's
it's certainly not a random sampling but
no but when we moved here
so getting recognized as a phenomenon of
life
pretty rare but um portland was the
place that used to happen least when we
moved here
at least of anywhere we traveled and um
so i do think people people are tuning
in more
yeah locally which is great the
the issue of people not really knowing
what's going on in portland
even people who live here is i think
huge
and it's it's not an accident yeah
part of it is covet has meant that
people who might be downtown more
frequently don't go
um but a there has been a concerted
effort which i've watched
on the portland subreddit to portray
reports of mayhem as false
as you know slanderous yeah um
and they're not right the mayhem is real
and in any case there's also an
instinct to look away right for those
especially people who
initially were excited about black lives
matter because they didn't read the fine
print
right those people have been
rationalizing
ever crazier ever more disconnected
behavior
and um it it does result in this sense
of like
why are we not you know why is andy know
the source of information on what's
going on with the rioters
right now i like quite a bit but
the point is there should be everybody
should be fascinated by what's happening
in a major american city
and instead the press is complicit in
not reporting it
and so what we have is so you don't mean
why is andy now doing this like why
why aren't there 20 andy knows right
so that we can get you know like you
know we have we literally our 17 year
old son's friend
happens to be there last night and we're
showing video from him
you know from
why is that where we're getting video
why isn't there actually journalism
being done
right there's no journal and in fact i
went because we aren't like we're not
journalists we're not pretending to be
journalists
right it's not our job but um but the
fact is there is a
journalistic vacuum surrounding what's
taking place and what is reported is
reported in such strange ways
right so i went looking for information
on the mural
that was painted on the apple store
because i wanted to make sure that apple
hadn't commissioned it which i was sure
they hadn't but i wanted to make certain
yeah and if you look at the reports
they're deliberately ambiguous
right this person chose to effectively
graffiti the wall that apple had put up
to cover the broken windows
now it happens they did an artistically
cogent job right but that shouldn't
matter
the point was maybe we decide that we
like this mural but the point is
somebody still decided
to violate the law and put up a mural
that spoke to their beliefs and not
our beliefs not apple's belief right
they chose to spray paint a wall
and anyway in the reports you have to
read
really carefully to figure out what
actually happened how that mural ended
up there
um so anyway yes there's a there's a
completely bizarre field of distortion
around
all the stories i would i mean probably
the people who
are in or around portland who are
watching this have done this but i
i actually encourage people to spend
time downtown in particular
um you know we haven't gone back at
night since the regular
riots stopped you know i just went down
maybe a couple times i think he went
down
one or two times more than that
but i have gone downtown many many times
in the daytime
and depending on if something just
happened the last night i may park up
actually
like at the japanese garden which is a
fair ways away and walk down
um just just so i don't have to worry
about like is my car gonna be vandalized
you know by the time i get back to it um
and it's always changing
and it's fascinating every time it's an
education every time you know the number
of
for a while there in the end of the
summer if i got downtown by
you know between 9 and 10 30 in the
morning
i always saw shopkeepers out on the
street
cleaning up the mess from the night
before and it's not that shopkeepers
don't
don't normally make sure to keep the
sidewalks in front of their stores
particularly clean
but this was a different level of
cleanup that they were being required to
do effectively in order to present a
welcoming
um storefront that really should not
have fallen on them
right you know especially especially in
these times when so much has already
fallen on small businesses
and i will say you know i hate this trip
i've always hated it since long before
the
pseudo left has been using it but like
i'm just so tired i just i just can't do
anything i'm just so tired like most
people use this and like
then stop doing all the stupid things
you're doing and like get some rest
and then do the things you actually want
to do and stop using this as an excuse
right now people are legitimately
exhausted because of
it like people are legitimately
exhausted and i do think that there are
some number of people who if they went
downtown and they saw it they would know
something different than what they
currently know
but they just cannot bring themselves to
and it is about
13 months of unprecedented
pandemic horribleness at all levels
well i think there's an added factor
i've always been
struck by the odd phenomenon of being
embarrassed on someone else's behalf
right when you see somebody do something
embarrassing and you feel embarrassment
on their behalf and
your instinct is to kind of obscure what
they're doing and
you know and i have the sense that this
is so because we believe in the dignity
of human beings at some level
right and you know this is shameful
right as a
as a portlander i want to be proud of
portland there's a lot that's
marvelous here but i'm ashamed of what
portland is doing i'm ashamed that
portland is allowing this to happen
right and so i think many people
who don't have our role
are looking away because it makes it
less bad except it doesn't what it means
is that
actually they're getting hoodwinked that
you've got a lot of people who are
um basically just misanthropic
and to allow the misanthropes to rule to
you know create a bailout fund and all
of this
it'd be hard if you looked at what
they're doing if you looked at what they
spray paint on the walls
right it's hard to imagine what would
move you to want them bailed out
right right i want them to suffer enough
that they stop yeah
they're advocating murder yes they're
openly advocating murder with a literal
smiley face yeah
right so and so what finally on this
topic
um at least for this set of questions um
why do we see the like martyring of men
who have actually
been engaged in violence against women
like
i i i feel like we've talked about this
a little bit certainly we have
um but i think we've talked about it
some on air before and i am
this is one of the things for me that
just sort of you know tears the
the facade off yeah it's like you oh you
you don't you don't care about women
right you don't care about fill in the
blank like you don't care about
any number of these things that you say
you care about unless it serves your
particular goal in the moment
and then you can then you can make a
claim that that's what you care about
but
um no it's it's true that there have
been a number of
men who have um died at the hands of
police
who have been who have been separately
engaged in
criminal violence against women and we
and
there was one like new york times like
front page story i think which just
spun the story of this guy i
can't remember any of this because i
don't know which story it was um
but just buried buried buried what
should have been the lead
which was actually here this
this person had been criminally violent
i don't remember okay well we'll stay
away from it yeah particulars i think i
know which story you're talking about
and
yes the um contrast between the actual
story of the individual
and the valorized version of the story
that was presented to the public was
like
we can heat like there are wrongful
deaths
by at the hands of police for sure
we can stand against that strongly and
fiercely
why would we valorize criminal behavior
well why would we do that
so i want to i want to spin it a little
bit okay
all right let's spin i want to twist
look at it differently turn
um here's the problem and you know eric
has done a thing where he's
called the the phenomenon optical
lynchings
where basically the point is if
something happens
that can be portrayed as the equivalent
of a lynching
than it is grabbed onto irrespective of
whether the facts actually add up
right and so if it looks like a cop has
murdered somebody
then that's good enough because what
we're really looking for is something
symbolic we're not looking for a factual
case
the point though is in a world where
you've got
people let's say that they earnestly
believe that
police-based you know racially motivated
injustice
at the hands of police is a rampant
problem right right they are looking for
examples to point out what we all know
is taking place
and the point is how many of these
examples have to turn out to be
not at all the way they were portrayed
for us to conclude the obvious thing
which is that
the case in which a truly innocent
person
a truly unarmed person is gunned down in
cold blood
right is actually rare right and so
i guess and of those cases the number of
those cases
that have a racial component is more
rare right
so i think the point is the
question is actually pointing at the um
the elephant in the room which is it is
the rarity of cases that are
truly clean and in which there is no
ambiguity
like this that causes the cases which
are so
compromised by the behavior of the
individual who's being valorized
to be so prominent yeah i mean
we probably don't want to spend a lot of
time here you know there is there's a
messiness here of course because i'm
reminded
in that argument of you know argument
that it's you know it's
hard to bring a rape con a rape case
against
a guy uh if his victim wasn't perfect
yeah right right if if she you know
especially if she was a sex worker but
if she um simply you know had a lot of
hookups if you know
if she you know like all of these things
right and you know
the fact is that rape should be rape
with the understanding that a whole lot
of things are being called rape that
aren't actually rape but like
rape is rape and it shouldn't matter
whether you know you
how the rest of the world views you and
whether or not
that should have happened to you well i
mean i agree with your point
but i think the thing is there's a
difference
between somebody whose record is
imperfect in which case i do think
it is fair to ask the question you know
what disadvantages resulted in the
person's criminal behavior
on the other hand rape is a special
crime
right abuse against an individual right
sexual assault against women is a crime
against an individual
yeah and the point is that if if the
allegations are
true then the point is okay this person
you're valorizing
actually harmed somebody egregiously
and they had a choice it wasn't that
they stole to you know to feed a family
they actually engaged in sexual violence
against an individual human they don't
deserve to be valorized this is
this is a kind of crime for which there
is no excuse yeah
it's it doesn't justify police violence
but um there's certainly no excuse for
valorization of the individual right
right exactly